[Music]
ideas and making ideas and making an
idea make ideas and make it come up with
ideas make it come up with ideas make it
cut them up with ideas make it I can't
even [ __ ] say it come up with ideas
and make it
[ __ ] the middle you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
advertising week in New York so that's
exciting to go give a keynote and then a
deep dive so and then later a panel with
tick tock so I'll be around here all day
so looking forward to it nothing much
more to add just a day in the life
obviously talks within the industry lead
to you know a lot of things customer
acquisition customer retention talent
acquisition talent retention just giving
back to the industry as a whole I like
it yards happiness yes what do you think
about the platform obviously you're a
big believer in it I always get excited
about when a platform starts hitting
tens if not hundreds of millions of
users there's actual attention on it and
I'm never scared if it's young or if
it's something else
what's ironic is the other thing I'm
most excited about right now is LinkedIn
I don't care that it used to be a
recruiting job board or platform or SAS
product it now is a Content hub I get
excited when something can become the
next YouTube or Facebook
whether tick-tock goes on and becomes
the next Instagram or not is irrelevant
to me
the ability to market right now to Gen Z
at scale is real now if you're selling
concrete to 80 year olds
tick-tock doesn't have to be for you the
reason somebody was selling to 55 year
old women as a CPG needs to look at it
as one those Gen Z kids may influence
the purchase behavior of that 55 year
old and two if it becomes a big platform
it's a place that you'd like to know
strategy and creative about to take
advantage whether it becomes vine or
social code or it becomes Facebook or
Instagram I don't know but it's hit the
scale and the consciousness that it now
deserves attention and making for it to
learn the strategies and nuances of the
platform that will allow you to become a
strong marketer and storyteller when it
hits your demographic if it hasn't
already thank you let's talk it out weak
but that doesn't matter what matters is
D rocks film drops at noon
you know wait so you guys are gonna
prompt a video we're gonna walk down
he'll introduce awesome
and so I do believe that the agencies
and brands that most figure out how to
actually produce thousands of pieces of
content that are relevant to the most
amount of end consumers that are
creating creative not two-for-one
specials this is not dr everybody want
to hear you know volume they're like oh
this is good for lower funnel conversion
absolutely not
yes it can work this is this is brand I
mean when is this industry gonna get
tired of producing an enormous amount of
expensive content that nobody actually
sees like what commercials are
penetrating our culture have you ever
been to a normal place and heard
somebody talking about a TVC like we the
stuff that people talk about is
happening within the internet and is
happening in all sorts of forms I
promise you way more normal people know
what the Instagram egg is then any
television commercial that came out
besides anything on the Superbowl and
that's something we need to think about
we just need to have that conversation I
understand ideologically that's not fun
to think about from a creative
standpoint but we need to go reverse we
need to be as religious as the great
skill of writing the copy for a tweet
that captures the attention of consumers
that can then bridge into a two minute
video that then can be the Super Bowl
spot for that brand we need to put that
on a pedestal we need to put
contemporary things on a pedestal
television commercials were completely
[ __ ] on by
add world because radio copy was the
pedestal this is historic this is what
always happens and this is the great
advantage this is the unlock if you're
curious about the Garry beeping right
one of the things that is so important
to me about continuously putting out
content one clearly through my DNA I
enjoy it and I want to communicate to
the world no different than anybody else
but you you have to you have to imagine
how nice it feels to me to sit on top of
a thousand person global agency at scale
and know deep down that there are very
few people on earth that are more of a
practitioner of creative and media
across all platforms than me you know
I'm competing with CEOs that have no
context and that's an advantage and it's
an audacious statement but there's a lot
of truth in it I'm putting out an
enormous amount of content daily and I'm
learning and it's built on humility I
never think I never think I'm right I
think the customers right and I just
watch what the customers doing
[Music]
you don't what what I think is next is
doing the things that are working right
now way more you know I don't I don't
get XP no honestly I don't want anything
to ever change I don't I don't predict
and I actually don't want anything to
ever change cuz I'm good at it I get sad
when Facebook Organic goes away and I
have to find the next thing cuz I spent
a lot of time and effort to be great at
it I think the answer is more more the
variable of success once you understand
the media framework that you guys are
playing in is the creative variable once
you know that tick tock or LinkedIn or
Instagram swipe ups are working the
answer is more contextual creative like
how many pre-roll podcast ads are being
read by influencers on their podcast
right now for your business answer is
probably none cuz I'm not talking about
it a whole lot yet sprinkled in here
there but there's probably a thousand
podcasts that you need to hand to hand
reach out to and say how much would it
cost for you to live read about our
product Howard Stern sold a lot of
product listen if you're Doug or if
you're Coco Co you want everybody in
this community to buy you like these
brands want all of us Nike 18t but like
they want us all think about how [ __ ]
hard that is it's completely impossible
with a [ __ ] 30-second video
completely so now figure it out I want
all of you to buy a banana how many
things do you think you need to do a lot
and so we need to stop wasting money in
meetings and debating to a 30-second
video and then post-production matching
luggage to that video in banner and
programmatic form because the KPI is
four dollar CPM not real life like we
need a complete rehaul of this industry
and here's the good news it's gonna
happen anyway because if it doesn't
happen the brands that do the smart [ __ ]
will become the biggest brands in the
world I want to remind you that Airbnb
and Netflix and many other things didn't
exist a decade ago in the way they look
today so things were coming
I think we should be on I just think of
this is one massive tidal wave and I
think you have a very simple choice do
what this industry does which puts its
head in the sand and just gets destroyed
by it or find some [ __ ] surf for life
[Music]
okay thank you bro
just gave some keynotes did an interview
for at age or the leading public one of
the leading publications in our industry
now going to have a quick meeting with
an entrepreneur that I've been promising
for a long time then going back then a
tick-tock session and then back to the
office to make it happen check it out
Gary Vaynerchuk next some of your best
buddies are gonna like have so much fun
with that
you know what's up Twitter is this
dropping on YouTube
yeah only what's good Twitter I'm sure
I'll be too I'm going to be tweeting
here in time all right in two minutes in
two minutes on YouTube I'm dropping a
film that the wonderfully talented D
rock made you know what's funny the rock
we're hyping this film and I don't think
you started making it with like this
much hype behind it so it's like a it's
like a solid moving average it's like an
average movie that were hyping a lot yo
my text homies
d-roc just finished off an incredible
film link in the text right now please
go watch this let me know what you think
super excited about it but most of all
on this Monday in the fall on a
beautiful day you've got to make a
decision
Thanks I'm sending a text to all of you
we're a part of the text - one two nine
three one five seven three one I was
really excited to the point where I had
the numbers so memorized that I could
drop the two one two nine three one five
seven thirty one so [ __ ] quick and
easy yeah I know what you're trying to
do like yes every text you get for me if
you signed up comes for me the replies
the push out this is literally me doing
it I just recorded it and now I'm typing
hey guys I made a film on YouTube that
just premiered right now
so there's 26 hundred of you watching
right now on trashed on live right now I
want all three thousand two hundred of
you to go hang up right now from the
live because I'm hanging up and you're
welcome
and I go go check it out it's real good
I think you're gonna like it
I think it's gonna help a lot of you I
really think there's something there
please check it out you know we don't
hide films often thank you love you love
you Instagram
what up ruff see you your name Harrison
Harrison nice to meet you bro and where
do you find Gary what where'd you find
him don't they talk yeah
thank you like for example I think the
next one should be about competition I
never talked about it like it'll be a
challenge to find [ __ ] like I believe
being competitive is an incredible
advantage that in our times of 2019 is
very balanced because it's why I care
about 8th place trophies if you
eliminate the goal but I also think the
world has abundance like I want to
destroy everybody's face in their every
agency but when somebody else if max
have an agency and it beat us or it won
the business that we were both going for
an adidas i weirdly am happy for him
even though I'm sad for me because I
love merit I love the games the game
like don't [ __ ] with competition let it
be pure don't demonize competition you
know win at all costs
is right in the framework of business
but not in life like I'm not gonna try
to like hurt Max's life but in business
I'd be like he sucks like you know like
it's kind of that whole thing so I think
competition something that I talk about
like why why doesn't why isn't in your
my wife well people with power trying to
change the rules you know like to me
like I I don't try to like break like
when I get old and have money I'm not
gonna try to change the tax law because
I'm tired and I'm scared of young buck
killing me cuz I'm killing old buck
right now and I should be killed that's
what I love about like nature like I
love that the old lion that killed
everybody when it's his time gets killed
and that's where people [ __ ] off
capitalism and competition they try to
change the rules when they're finished I
have no respect for old liens trying to
change the rules of the jungle because
they want to keep eating it's time for
them to die love that about sports
LeBron's not going to be able to
continue doing LeBron in 12 years
I love the purity of competition even at
my own expense
but I think it matters I also think we
need to you know really respect like
right now we're in a era where one could
demonize Alfa competitive you know like
I don't know like you know like I think
we're I think balance is everything
everything I talk about is extremes on
both sides and really I don't use the
word a lot it won't show up in my in my
word cloud but almost everything I'm
actually talking about is balance
a balanced conversation around
competition would be a really healthy
one so like that's anyway nonetheless
that was obviously reintroduce some
content but once a quarter and then and
then the other thing I want from you I
thought about this weekend is I want you
to make things on the spot when I
[ __ ] feel like I can impose them on I
can have my cake and eat it too you're
there you're like doing this new thing I
want to make sure like when we have a
real moment and we all look at each
other I just want to know that's been
minute the next morning sandy and said
and maybe that's gonna mix up people
some new people four people nice little
mix call Andy let's get a four person
five person mix I want them to go live
on LinkedIn and talking to my audience
about the film without me there since
they can go live on LinkedIn
and you can get five people a diverse
group of men and women all kind of
creeds and do a LinkedIn live right now
about this film and say Gary isn't isn't
just called us and told us go live about
this film here's how we made it hunters
we thought about it he's not live
because Lincoln isn't live on mobile yet
but he wanted to get out about it the
link to the film is in here he want to
give behind the curtains because he
hopes it inspires some of you to make a
film for your company like ideas and
making idea call these are making said
ideas and making ideas and making an
idea make ideas and make it come up with
ideas make it come up with ideas make it
cut them up with ideas make it I can't
even [ __ ] say it come up with ideas
and make it
[ __ ] the middle
[Music]
in this talk about tick-tock with one of
the senior executives from tick-tock
should be fun right I mean you guys have
seen the manifestation of the platform
in my perspective in a super-rad
auditorium so imax like yeah I mean it's
it's it's it's it's it's historically
correct you know all that tick-tock it
for me being the first friend to go
heavy into tick-tock that is targeting
that demo because I still don't fully
know where the demos but let's let's
just say skews younger for now is no
different than Procter & Gamble being
the biggest spender on television in the
50s and 60s because that was the
arbitrage or wish the shopping app you
probably knew this I mean this is what
Facebook executives joke about all the
time there's all these companies and
LLC's that nobody's ever heard of
spending uncomfortable amounts of money
and coke and BMW are spending a third of
that and everyone's confused what's
going on to me if you're selling to 15
to 25 year-olds anything and you don't
have an uncomfortable strategy
uncomfortable as a slang term for all in
creating everyday at scale on tick-tock
you're missing one of the great kind of
moments and the [ __ ] can go away you
know and and and it could and still goes
with you one of things that I'm always
fascinated by is people like well Gary
what if it goes away in three years I'm
like you take the brand equity with you
there was a lot of people who built a
lot of brand equity on vine and when
they started creating on snap or
Instagram the audience a percentage of
it went I don't know why everybody's so
literal you're so happy to mark it on
Super Bowl or on television or an
outdoor that goes away to but there's
something
ideological in the system that has this
sad feeling that it might turn into
MySpace
you know my preference is that they all
die because that means the attention is
moving and it will always benefit the
quickest and the people that are most
willing to play that game which is my
most comfortable game
you know I love having debates with
people about the past the past is always
people's vulnerability to the current
and definitely to the future
[Music]
what's up vlog you know obviously we've
done a better job now so I'm just in
took the camera
Max is having a weird day cuz he was
told that he's not as good-looking as me
by me so that was good tea rocks
probably going through his own set of
emotions because the films out and he's
probably deciding what he likes and
doesn't like I'm never really sure what
Jason's thinking that's just kind of how
it is but it's always good feels warm
and happy to me how's traffic good
Xochitl hundred ten minutes I'm getting
nine minutes back it's a good day give
me those [ __ ] nine minutes [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know it is the truth
great content always wins it's just true
lat me out of agreement 100%
you give the best mic the best slides
the best auditorium you're not gonna
beat my talk I'm gonna do it on a
cardboard box a [ __ ] sidewalk there
are thousand episodes of y9b TV with no
audio no lighting not all 1000 episodes
of wine library are done a camera and
again honey like whatever the [ __ ]
camera picked up no lighting [ __ ]
everybody went out Mead highly produced
wine videos that it was gonna take me
out with production production never
beats story why cuz the story is the
punch line now production can add to the
story like Avatar
Star Wars is [ __ ] amazing but don't
get it twisted that [ __ ] story
matters you don't think there's been
highly produced Hollywood [ __ ] movies
made with those great [ __ ] cameras do
that suck
Waterworld [ __ ] suck that's amazing
we've built some environments for kids
yes just two years such a pleasure
so nice to meet you yeah have a great
day take care what's going on guys we
just got back to the office full
afternoon of meetings Monday got a lot
of work to do let's get it yes next week
three or four nights in New York thank
you
I'll tell ya mostly sound right now
talk to me nice and I'll talk to me I'll
let it get you madness
what's go hey everybody welcome to a
very special episode of the podcast my
friend Jimmy is here we've met for a
hundredth of a second so we're going
right into this cuz I'm excited about
this Jimmy I think it'll be really fun
for everybody please tell everybody why
the [ __ ] you were here and more poorly
actually what I'm actually asking Jimmy
is how did you get here remind everybody
on the opportunity I answered the they
give away that you had on the text
platform mm-hm
went onto Twitter use the hashtag
explained you know I think there's a
little bit about like you know why do
you want to be on the podcast yeah I got
a question on the askgaryvee show
thirty years ago i've been doing a
little bit of stuff but not like really
going hard at it you know like I should
be and I just put my story out there a
little a little bit use me for it up
because I'm gonna let you take over from
here everybody's listening the reason
this podcasts fun for me is obviously
I've started doing a lot of text
messaging on this platform called
community that I'm using and a couple
things one yes it's me every single text
every single time you get a reply it's
always me I believe you
thank you that's why I'm using audio and
video so for everybody's wondering it's
always me obviously I'm putting out
stuff you know every day every other day
every couple days but what I'm obsessed
with is if I'm gonna put out hey watch
the rocks new movie or hey sign up for
wine texts if I'm gonna be in the right
hook on a text I think unlike social I
need to be very careful there you know
it's a very special place your phone
numbers so I'm obsessed with bringing
values so I've decided that for
everybody who signed up for my text
messaging platform it's gonna be the
place where I create access where my
thing is like if you're working and
you're doing your life stuff if you put
out so much content it would literally
be like the same content every day
I think it's a really good question
couple things especially if you're
wanting to do something this like travel
this is madness
this is where creativity and ideas has
to be something I talked more about so
for example when I think about a hundred
pieces of content a day and this is
great because it seems like you're
grounded in Twitter most more than many
because you were part of that era with
me yeah I think Twitter is an incredibly
important part of the hundred piece
concept you know obviously this is
catching and I'm getting asked about it
more so this is a great opportunity to
create some clarity hopefully the team
clicks this lets get raw Gogh to write a
piece you know the hundred piece concept
2.0 I think we're working on something
but but Twitter is incredibly important
as you know one of the great things
about Twitter is it's trending topics
and the ability to reply to it with
retweeting and adding your two cents or
typing original thoughts so for me one
of the things that really stands out is
if I was asking the normal quote-unquote
person to produce 100 pieces of content
a day I guarantee you that I'm probably
subconsciously thinking that 50 of those
are Twitter you can write you can
retweet and add your two cents all of a
sudden you're kind of there right the
other thing is I don't think people
understand document versus create I
think people think you need d-roc or
Jayson following you dustin following
you around I think it's just taking a
picture like I see content right here
like I see content and maybe I have this
is probably my strengths I see content
and everything I think you should take a
photo of us talking right now and tweet
it and be like holy [ __ ] I'm doing this
with Gary B right now yeah like okay
there's Madison Square Garden yeah and
you know like like this is New York you
know like like I think there's a lot
more content and by the way I think that
could be done 15 to 20 times on Twitter
Instagram stories and tick tock without
any cost to the preciousness that is the
main reason that everybody can't make
100 pieces of content you know taking a
photo of what you see and adding one
sentence is allowing people into your
world and you start creating around
common interests there you know a lot of
people like Gary's should I separate my
business of life I'm like I put my Jets
content in my all my content I put my
garage sale stuff there that has nothing
to do
the marketing or the business running
like I think it's there but I do think
it's a strategy mindset and I think
everybody thinks this is useless and
nobody would care and I think you should
let them decide
[Music]
we're never stressed I know my buddies
also